- - Martine Biron, Josée Legaul,
ChChristian Biron bonsoir. Je vs
fafaire écouter ce qui n'était s
avavec nous début d'émission.
MoMonsieur Legault qui dit que a
papatience a des limites.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, premier
miministre du Québec
- - Ma patience a atteint
sasa limite. C'est important
ququ'on laisse nos enfants
pupuis les patients en paix.
EtEt puis qu'on n'ait pas
ceces manifestants antivaccin.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Laissez nos enfants
trtranquilles. On ne peut pas
totolérer une situation où
dedes enfants sont pris en otag,
ouoù il y a de l'intimidation
ququi se fait près de nos école.
JeJe pense qu'on est à
dedes risques de débordement.
LeLes parents sont inquiets
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - On tente de dissuader des
enenfants de respecter les mesus
sasanitaires. C'est inadmissibl.
EtEt comme on l'a fait dans le s
dedes cliniques d'avortement,
c'c'est possible d'intervenir
spspécifiquement sur
ceces situations-làà
popour que ça arrête.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - On a le droit de s'exprimer
enen société, mais si, claireme,
dadans le cadre d'un sujet
ouou d'une manifestation,
çaça pose un problème de sécurié
popour des citoyens.
EÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Québec
- - Il faut que cette loi-là
enencadre l'ensemble des citoyes
ququébécois et pour ça, il faut
ququ'on comprenne où ils veulent
alaller. Là pour l'instant, tout
cece que l'on a, c'est le minise
ququi court après Claire Samson
popour lui dire : "J'ai besoin
dede ton consentement", puis qud
elelle lui demande sur quoi,
ilil n'est pas capable de
lele détailler. Donc on va faire
leles choses dans le bon ordre,
pupuis on ne donnera pas un chèe
enen blanc, contrairement
auaux trois autres partis
d'd'opposition, au gouvernement
popour qu'il fasse ce qu'il veu.
- - Parce qu'on l'a entendu,
MaMartine, les partis d'oppositn
sosont d'accord. Ils allons-y pr
évéviter même des débordements.n
a a des parents qui de l'autre
ccôté seraient un maudit compte
leles manifestants. Ça pourrait
dédégénérer. Alors, est-ce que
c'c'est réglé politiquement,
MaMartine? On a l'appui de Toul?
ToToute action s sur le fondemet
dedes d'accord. Mais je pense qe
totout le monde veut voir le
prprojet de loi et/ou il va avec
çaça.
IlIl y a aussi une forme une joe
popolitique qui se prépare. Quie
prprésente devant nous. D'abord,
lele gouvernement veut pousser
efeffectivement les conservateus
d'd'Éric Duhaime dans les câble.
C'C'est-à-dire que s'il refuse e
dodonner son consentement,
çaça va le poursuivre, ça va
didiminution, un cadeau pour
MoMonsieur logo qui va pouvoir
ututiliser agnosie âme en Khatti
mimitoyenne électorale en disan:
reregardez les consommateurs ce
sosont ceux qui ont laissé ses
mimilitants administratifs est
écécrits des bêtises aux enfant.
DeDeuxièmement Monsieur Legault
agagit assez rapidement parce qe
leles libéraux étaient très
avavancés dans ce dossier-là il
esest en train de se faire des
amamis plombs par les libéraux l
y y a. Hier c'est ce qu'elle a
didit, Madame Anglade était prêe
cece matin.
EtEt ce qui me satisfasse cet
apaprès-midi à la période des
ququestions, Monsieur Legault a
prpris une question de Marwah
RiRizqy.
GéGénéralement le chef répare ds
chchefs. Il va assumer ou assurr
soson leadership sur ses dossies
llà.
- - Est-ce que ça vous étonne ou
papas cet unanimisme presque en
didisant il faut limiter la
pepermission de manifester devat
dedes écoles.
- - Non pas du tout, premièremet
paparce que c'est de
l'l'intimidation. On a pu pendat
lala campagne fédérale aussi des
mamanifestants très agressives,
tatalonné Justin Trudeau aussi
popour les mêmes raisons.
EtEt je pense que e les
paparlementaires comprennent qul
fafaut agir avant justement qu'l
y y a un drame.
OnOn a vu aujourd'hui que ce n't
pepeut-être pas des manifestant,
mamais un infirmière qui était
tatabassée à Sherbrooke par un
hohomme qui était mécontent qui
prprétendait que sa femme avait
étété vaccinée contre son gré.
IlIl y a une montée de colère cz
unune petite partie de la
popopulation, mais c'est là quea
pepeut dégénérer comme vous le
didisiez si bien tout à l'heure.
NoNon je ne suis pas étonné du
totout. Et Éric Duhaime et Claie
SaSamson le sait quand on sait
ququ'on peut leur donner ces dee
jojoindre au mouvement parce que
sisinon ils vont perdre le peu e
crcrédibilité qu'il reste.
- - Christelle c'est un beau déi
popour Éric Duhaime la?
- - Oui c'est vrai qu'un consens
asassez rare sur le principe que
leles manifestations du vaccin
n'n'ont pas leur place vers les
hhôpitaux et les écoles. Ce sont
dedes petites populations
vuvulnérables et facilement
inintimidant.
EtEt un tas d'autres endroits ds
lala ville où les gens sont
cocomptés vaccin peut manifeste.
CeCeci dit) sans que la police
didisposait déjà des moyens en
fafait pour contrôler ça, mais a
nene semble pas le cas. Donc ona
vovoir la loi parce qu'on touche
ququand même quelque chose
d'd'important. Le droit de
mamanifester. Ça évite aussi à
rarappeler que les g gens qui st
cocomptés vaccin, ils ont le drt
d'd'être comptés vaccin.
OnOn est en train des traités
sysystématiquement en paria. Ce
ququi est odieux. Ils ont droite
mamanifester ailleurs. Moi je
trtrouve qu'ils ont tort, ses
cocomptes de ne pas se faire
vavacciner, mais ils ont droit e
fafaire.
- - Ils ont droit de manifester
dedes les rues de Montréal, mais
dedevant une école où on va
rereconduire nos petites filles.
- - Dans la société, ça va plus
loloin que ça. Espèce
d'd'agressivité à l'égard des
cicitoyens qui ne fêtent pas se
fafaire vacciner. Mais je veux
leleur appliquer un côté qui pet
dodonner odieux. Pourrait Duhai,
c'c'est un test très important
paparce qu'il représente en fait
dede ceux qui ont des problèmes
avavec la façon de gérer la crie
sasanitaire du gouvernement
LeLegault.
LaLa c'est un dossier extrêmemet
dédélicat ai-je l'impression qul
vava se rallier au consensus, en
reregardant ce que c'est la loi
prprécisément.
IlIl ne faut pas donner un chèqe
enen blanc gouvernement, ce n'et
papas rien le droit manifester.
- - Da carrière un utilisant
apapprendre vite, vite, vite
dedemain quand Clara le texte et
chchoisir la voie qui va choisi.
IlIl y a des hôpitaux qui sont
blbloqués sans rien avoir avec s
mamanifestants, ça va être le
mamanque infirmière. Avec le
mamanque de personnel et l'hôtel
dudu Chili vous on a commencé
l'l'émission chez Martine de
KiKivisto gens ne pas venir à
l'l'urgence. À Valleyfield, avat
enen Haïti ministère des urgenc.
LaLa crise attribue l'ampleur de
cece manque de personnel. C'est
coconcret.
DeDemain la barre est haute
LeLegault a dit qu'on veut tout
fafaire est-ce que les plans il
esest ficelé d'après ce que vous
enentendez? Parce que ça peut
fafaire une faire différence
- - XT savait politiquement
pépérilleux cet exercice-là pare
quque Monsieur Dubé a laissé
enentendre que c'était une
opopportunité cette pandémie la
coconduite pour faire des choses
ququ'on n'avait jamais faites,
mamais réorganiser ce système, a
vava vouloir dire des changemen.
EtEt de changement c'est pas
fafacile. Son succès passe en
AbAbitibi, on a vu qu'on a perms
papar exemple des petit CLSC por
enenvoyer des infirmières et des
reressources dans de plus gros,n
a a centralisé les ressources ds
didifférents endroits. Alors
cocomment est-ce que ça va se
papasser sur le terrain? Comment
cece que les infirmières vont
réréagir?
EsEst-ce que ça veut dire du
dédéplacement personnel. Est-ce
ququ'on va éliminer les heures
susupplémentaires obligatoires?
LeLes attentes sont très élevées
dudu côté des infirmières, mais
c'c'est certain qu'on ne fait ps
d'd'omelettes sans casser de fir
leles pressions que la douzainea
y y passer X avait de gros
chchangements pour les infirmiès
quque c'est difficile les
chchangements prendre, de changr
dede travail.
- - Il faut plutôt décider de ne
papas les choquer. José Christin
évévolue ces données infirmière,
ilil faut qu'elle revienne.
- - Bien enfin il y a plusieurs
cocorps de métiers dans le syste
dede santé québécois qui aurait
bebesoin d'une grande séduction
papas seulement les infirmières,
mamais c'est crucial en effet.
EÉcoutez, il y a tellement de
prproblèmes on ne sait pas parùu
cocommencer. On les connaît deps
dedes années, dont justement
ceces conditions de travails qui
n'n'ont qu'un bon sens. Le travl
susupplémentaire obligatoire. Qi
fafait qu'il y a une exode sur e
tatard vers les agences privées
cocomme le gouvernement fait
afaffaire avec les agences
prprivées, c'est le cercle vicix
dadans lequel les gouvernementse
sosont enfermés depuis plusieurs
anannées. Donc, oui va falloir n
rérécupérer une partie, mais ça
veveut dire aussi qu'il va fallr
cocommencer à ce utiliser moins
leles agences privées par
dédéfinition. Donc, ce sont
tetellement d'éléments est bon,e
miministre de la santé Christian
DuDubé est un homme courageux, n
lele sait. On attend beaucoup de
lului est-ce qu'on espère surto,
c'c'est que s'il y a quelque che
ququi débloque de ce côté-là de
mamanière positive, est-ce que l
popourrait appliquer une recett,
papas exactement la même, mais
sisimilaires justement pour
d'd'autrtres professions qui sot
mamalmenées dans le système de
sasanté.
EtEt où justement il y a des ges
ququi étaient avec la pandémie,
ququi a été vraiment la goutte i
a a fait déborder le vase pour
bebeaucoup de monde.
- - Des fois ça prend des grosss
crcrises, Christian, pour trouvr
dedes solutions qu'on osait
prpratiquer. Est-ce que ça sera
dedemain vous croyait?
- - Écoutait Dominique Christian
DuDubé a une crédibilité certaie
dadans ce domaine-là. Il a mis n
jejeu parce qu'il a dit qu'il ny
auaurait pas de bris de service.
LeLes gendres de maman disent
Monsieur Dubé réunissant
ququelques semaines, parce qu'iy
a a quand même l'échéance pour s
ininfirmières et les travers dea
sasanté qui ne sont pas vaccinés
ququi vont devoir quitter.
CeCelui-ci en quelques semainesà
rérégler en faite à faire sauver
unun système exemple depuis
lolongtemps, je pense que la cre
sasanitaire, c'est révélateur.
DuDu fait qu'un système de santé
ququi monopolise faut-il rappelr
5050 % des ressources du Québec,
n'n'est pas fonctionnel. Ce n'et
papas juste la crise sanitaire,
ararrivé quelque chose c'est trs
didifficile de réformer ça.
MoMonsieur Dubé Capa, François
LeLegault 2000 devraient
dédémissionner et qui semble Dué
dedevait premier du Québec. On
paparle, déjà ne pense pas que e
prproblème c'est les agences
prprivées sont beaucoup plus
prprofonds que ça ça ne m'en fae
dede contourner les Québécois.
J'J'ai passé le dernier quelque
chchose qui ne marche pas dans e
sysystème bureaucratique
paparticulier dans le santé. Je
sosouhaite désespérément que
MoMonsieur Dubé et des
ininformations qui lui permet de
pepenser que oui il y a pas
susubstantiellement des services
mmêmes si plusieurs personnes qi
enen a déjà.
- - José, les conditions sont
memeilleures pour les infirmièr.
- - Oui tout à fait pour avoir
réréalisé moi-même le système de
sasanté sur toutes les coutures
dedepuis de nombreuses années, e
sasais très bien que les agences
prprivées sont un problème parmi
d'd'autres, mais c'est un proble
imimportant. Et tous ces
prproblèmes-là qui ont existé en
amamont, qui ont éclaté, qui ont
exexposé littéralement depuis le
dédébut de la pandémie, ensuite
susuccès aux milices Dubé et on
sosouhaite qu'il s'attaque ensue
àà la première ligne parce que i
leles urgences continuent à
dédéborder au Québec,
c'c'est parce que justement, on
n'n'a pas réussi les gouvernemes
popourrisse à établir une premie
liligne solide.
LeLes infirmières ont un rôle
auaussi à jouer dans
l'l'établissement d'une première
liligne Bruxelles et de Québec.
ToTout accès OK Monsieur Dubé fe
àà une machine qui est tout sauf
flflexible. Prenez les conventis
cocollectives avec les infirmiès
ququi ont été réglées cet été. n
esestime que pour mettre ensembe
dedes nouvelles mesures en place
ilil va falloir autour d'un an
popour appliquer les conventions
cocollectives. C'est comme
hahallucinant.
- - On a comme choix.
OnOn ne peut pas fermer un nombe
ququi grandit d'urgence comme ç.
M'M'en donner simple bon sens. n
esest-elle dans le Sanofi bon
sesens. La nécessité et la mèree
l'l'invention. On le souhaite
dedemain. On verra ça. Je ne sei
papas là demain mais je peux vos
reregarder de loin.
EÉlections fédérales, Trois-
RiRivières est-ce qu'on a un
rérésultat coup donc on doit ête
àà 16h50. Trois-Rivières
ststalactites réglées. Ces
MoMonsieur Bulmer le Blomqvist u
l'l'ancien maire conservateur on
nene le sait pas pour l'instanÀA
susuivre. Mais je faire entendre
MoMonsieur Blanchet qui a fait a
prpremière conférence de presse
poposte soirée électorale.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef du Bloc Québécois
- - La responsabilité d'obtenir
dedes appuis, c'est celle
dudu premier ministre, c'est pas
lala mienne. C'est celle du
prpremier ministre de faire
mamarcher son gouvernement.
EtEt il est dans une situation i
esest singulièrement avantageus,
paparce qu'il y a trois petits
amamis dans la classe.
IlIl suffit qu'il y en est un
dedes trois qui soit d'accord
avavec lui et il est correct.
AlAlors la responsabilité de fae
susurvivre le gouvernement libél
dede Justin Trudeau, soyez assus
quque ce sera pas ma préoccupatn
prpremière.
- - Mais en disant qu'il
sosouhaitait que ça dure un
cecertain temps, on va se
reretrouver en campagne électore
bibientôt. Il pense aux trois as
ilil prend soin des
nénéoconservateurs bien sûrs età
lului. Qui peuvent entre-temps
sasauver le gouvernement. Alors,
dadans quel état d'esprit il s'n
vava Tahoua le chef du bloc, Jo?
- - Je pense que sans valeur das
lele même état d'esprit que les
auautres chefs de parti
d'd'opposition. C'est-à-dire que
pepersonne au Canada ne veut d'e
élélection d'ici six mois, un a,
1818 mois, etc. Lorsqu'il dit qe
lala responsabilité va être ente
leles mains de Justin Trudeau, a
reresponsabilité va et aussi ene
leles mains des chefs
d'd'opposition, dont lui. Je pee
ququ'on s'en va vers un parlemet
ququi va être stable équivalentà
popossiblement longtemps. Et
mamalgré le fait que ce soit un
gogouvernement minoritaire,
jujustement, à cause de toutes s
cocontroverses qui entouraient e
dédéclenchement des élections, r
MoMonsieur Trudeau, et donc non,
jeje pense que Monsieur Blanchet
vava devoir collaborer lui auss.
AvAvec les objets de position.
- - Christian.
- - On verra, c'est assez
didifficile de prévoir ce qui va
ararriver dans ces situations-l.
JeJe comprends qu'on est obligée
l'l'analyser.
MoMoi j'ai pas beaucoup apprécié
lele temps de Monsieur Blanchet.
IlIls encore campagne littorale
irirrégulière pas moyen pendant4
ujujourd des positifs? C'est pe-
êêtre un peu formel, un peu nia
ninia,
- - il était pas très bon humeu,
bebeaucoup l'ont noté.
- - Oui c'est ça et moi je troue
ququ'il a le droit, mais je troe
çaça correct. C'est un gros efft
unune élection, tout le monde a
trtravaillé demander à bout de
sosouffle avoir un nouveau
gogouvernement risque moyen des
popositifs quelques jours.
- - Martine?
- - On va lui envoyer une petite
nonote.
- - Je pense qu'il souhaitait
gagagner quelque chose pour les0
sisièges, c'est quand même pas
ininnocent. 47 Cévennes cette
babase-là, il aurait eu la
mamajorité des sièges au Québec.
LeLe bloc depuis sa création
jujusqu'à la vague orange en 201
a a toujours eu la majorité des
sisièges au Québec.
AlAlors s'il avait réussi à verr
4040 sièges a été une victoire
pepersonnelle importante et il e
l'l'a pas obtenue.
JeJe pense que sur la balance du
popouvoir, de voir que le NPD et
ququand même là, il se retrouve
dadans une situation où il sait
cacarrément le statu quo. Et le
blblog, n'aura pas plus
d'd'importance. Monsieur Legault
nene fera pas faire avec Yves-
FrFrançois Blanchet, ce ne sont
papas des amis, ils se
coconnaissent, se respectent, ms
MoMonsieur Legault va transiger
didirectement avec Justin Trudeu
mmême ça sera pas chaleureux.
- - Le caucus québécois des
lilibéraux fédéraux et en furie
évévidemment quand Monsieur
LeLegault pour les raisons qu'on
coconnaît. Ça sera voir la suite
dedes choses. Combien de temps?n
enencore du temps.
LLà-dessus un puceau comment vos
vovoyez la suite des choses?,
ChChristian?
- - Moi je sais Québec
acactuellement je pense au
trtroisième lien. Il me semble
ququ'il y a quelque chose qui et
enen danger, dans les beaux
prprojets Monsieur Legault, c'et
lele troisième lien à Québec est
imimportant pour une partie
imimportante de la population. e
nene sais pas ce que Martin en
pepense, je ne peux pas jouir
cocomme un expert station
sisituation politique de Québec.
EsEst-ce que ça va faire l'affae
dede François Legault que le
trtroisième ligne se réalise pa.
MaMais si on a décidé de se
vevenger, assez clair.
- - José, il y a une tension das
l'l'air disons.
- - Oui c'est tout à fait norma.
JeJe veux dire la sortie de
MoMonsieur Legault en faveur des
bleueus conservateurs, c'était
ququand même faire éclater.
C'C'était Fabrice qui même
lolorsqu'elle Legault la fête.
EnEnvoyé bien qu'est-ce qui état
plplus probable c'est un
gogouvernement libéral
miminoritaire. Donc, c'est ce qi
vava y avoir des pourra réparés,
c'c'est clair. Mais bon je pense
quque les choses vont finir pare
tatasser, mais le gros os c'este
trtransfert en santé